I was going to try and explain a bit
about a result called Vandiver dance
theorem which is one of the fundamental
results of Ramsey theory which is an
area that I'm very interested in Vander
burn serum is about coloring the
positive integers so you take the
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 and so on and to each
one you assign a color and the idea is
that you only have finitely many colors
to use however you do it it's possible
to find an arithmetic progression that
is a set of integers like 5 9 13 17 21
whether step between each one and next
is the same however long you want
a game with the following rules we start
with two numbers let's say 28 and 13 and
I say to you you've got 13 colors to use
I want you to try and color the positive
integers that is a sign one of these 13
colors to each positive integer in such
a way that I can't find an arithmetic
progression of length 28 that only uses
one color however you choose your
coloring with 13 colors standardless
theorem says I'm always going to win
that game I'm always going to be able to
find somewhere an arithmetic progression
of lengths 28 that only uses one color
and it's your choice what the gap of
that progression is yeah I get to choose
sometimes it's called the common
difference sometimes it's called the
step of the arithmetic progression so
yes I can't tell you in advance what the
step will be that will depend on how you
choose to do the coloring actually I can
explain that straight away so supposing
in addition I needed to find a
progression where the step was 3 so 28
numbers all three apart yeah you could
easily stop that even with just two
colors you could color red red red blue
blue blue red red red blue blue blue and
each number would have a different color
from the number 3 on so I couldn't even
find an arithmetic progression of legs 2
with just one color if we insisted that
the step was 3 so for me to have a
winning strategy I have to be allowed to
choose the step but if I'm allowed to
choose the step and I can win the game
well I thought I might start with the
very very simplest case which is what
happens if you just want to find an
arithmetic progression of length 2 so if
you think about that for a second here
as that is actually extremely easy and
then suppose we have 2 colors of red and
blue so without loss of generality 1 is
colored blue now if I want to avoid an
arithmetic progression of length 2 in
one color
I'd better color to red and now what
about 3 if I color it blue I have an
arithmetic progression of length 2 and
step 2 but if I'd colored it red I'd
have had an arithmetic progression of
length 2 and step 1 so that's not a very
hard problem as soon as you've got two
things of the same color so if a number
of colors is 75 and as soon as you've
colored 76 numbers and by the famous
result known as the pigeonhole principle
there must be two
that are the same color and having two
of the same color is the same as having
an arithmetic progression of length to
the first truly interesting case of Van
de Vence theorem is something that I
think it's not too hard to explain but
it's quite subtle and the ideas that go
into the proof of the whole theorem are
already present in this special case so
the idea is actually to make use of this
very simple case of progression to
length 2 and also to make use of the
pigeonhole principle that I've just
mentioned and put them together in a
clever way and then you can get that if
you have two colors then I will be able
to find a progression of lengths three
that just uses one color okay so I've
got there's two colors being used for
the coloring in you want to find a
progression of three so three numbers
that have a regular step either yeah
regular step and either red red red or
blue blue blue so I'm going to show that
it's impossible for you to avoid that
situation if you color enough numbers
okay so the way to prove this let's take
a block of five numbers now what I'd
like to do is focus on the first three
numbers and how those are going to be
colored now we know from what we just
said that there will be two of the first
three that have the same color so this
is actually the same argument that I've
just been talking about oh three could
be the same color oh yeah it's all three
is when I say too I mean at least two
have to be the same color now that's an
important point so whatever happens in
the first three I have I have at least
two that have the same color so let's
suppose it's this one here I'll just
represent it by a blob rather than
writing a number and this one here it
doesn't really matter now if you're
trying to avoid a progression of length
three and once you've got those two that
are the same color that's going to force
the color of one of the other ones
because they were in the first three
whichever one they so to speak point two
has to be the opposite color so we've
got something like that otherwise I'd
have had blue blue blue with a step of
two and I would have been very happy I
won the game and that wasn't the only
possibility another possibility it might
have been that the first two were red
but in that case we could have been
absolutely sure that the third one was
blue so I'm not saying that this precise
configuration has to happen
but something like this has to happen
within the first five you're going to
have to have two that are the same color
and take the same step and reach a third
one that has the opposite color and
there's only have a certain number of
ways that you can do that so now what we
do is we divide the integers into blocks
of five so there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
I'm not writing in the numbers and
putting dots instead from back here
there's only a certain number of ways
that we could get a configuration like
this I'm gonna keep can't while I did it
so it could be blue blue red or if we
read Red's lose or if we blues blue red
or if we read reds blues or it could be
second or third one blue two blue blue
red or red red blue I've got up to 6 so
there are 6 different ways so it's which
one you leave out that gives you three
choices and whether the two that go in
the other two places are blue or red
that makes it up to six choices at least
one of these six configurations has to
occur however I color the first five
things so now what I'm going to do is
look at these blocks I know that each
one has got one of six configurations
like this by the pigeonhole principle
again if I color these blocks as soon as
I've colored more than six of them two
of them must have the same configuration
of this kind they aren't necessarily
identical are they but they have that
killer configuration they do actually if
you wanted to you could make them
identical and this is the way it's
usually presented so how many ways are
there occurring the first five there are
32 ways of doing it so I could if I
wanted to fill up 33 blocks and then I'd
have two that actually were colored in
precisely the same way yep but I'll do
it this way for today doesn't matter so
that is because there are only six for
what we really care about right there's
a killer diamond and then the other ones
can be sort of even just left uncut a
little bit so let's just suppose that
this block had a red I'll choice a
different way now red red blue and this
block here also had a red red blue so we
know that somewhere we're going to be
able to find - so we've got red red blue
we have a red red blue let's take the
block that is the same distance from
this one as this one is from this one so
go the same step
it doesn't matter discipline this one
I've drawn it two away but it could have
been five away whatever happens I just
the same step along now let's try to
color this so so far this is sort of not
exactly forced but up to which one of
these things I happen to choose your
forces to have something like this so
once you've done that let's just think
how to color this so this one here well
I've got red and then I jump up by 10
and I've got red and so this one had
better be blue otherwise I've won the
game this one's red this one's red so
this one better be blue as well what
about this one that's blue and that's
blue so that had better be red the
redness of red here was a force to move
yeah but now let's have a look at the
first one here and I'll jump up by 12 to
the second one here and then by another
12 to the third one here I've got red
red red victory although what I've drawn
is a special case you can see I think
that if it had been that configuration
and they'd been for a part instead of
two apart or it had been blue blue red
and they'd been even sort of 9 apart I
could have the same strategy of looking
at the one that was the same distance
along and looking at what it had to be
here and here and here one would have
ended actually there were two reasons
this had to be red there was this blue
blue red and I was this blue blue red
but there's also the red red red which
means that once it's been forced then
actually the game was lost for anyone
who's trying to avoid a progression at
length 3 this red red blue configuration
is not the only configuration among our
six killers but all six of those killers
have a similar property delay assumed
right so maybe I could just actually
illustrate one more example so supposing
it it and have not been red red blue
like that it but it has just been first
two blue and the third one red supposing
when I find two blocks that have the
same configuration a configuration that
they share is blue blue red and so
somewhere along here I've also got blue
blue red so then over here so that blue
blue forces are red and this blue blue
forces are red and then the red red
forces are blue but then I've got that
one yes
and that one and that one ah listen I'll
give me sometimes known as the color
focusing argument because these two
colors focus on that point and force it
to be red if you're trying to win the
game but those two focus on the deposit
to be blue
they can't be both red and blue you're
telling me that we're a lot more paper
and a lot more pens a lot more time this
argument would work for nineteen colors
and a progression of 40 and things like
that yes so if you want to do in another
case that's just a little bit bigger
maybe three colors and progression of
lengths three or something then it it
turns out to be not that much more
complicated I won't actually try to do
it but I just say that pigeonhole
principle what enabled us to say as long
as you take enough blocks you can find
two that are colored in the same way or
actually as we did it two that contain
the same little configuration of this
kind for a later version you might need
to have three things that are colored in
exactly the same way that have the same
step between them but once you know
Vandor burdens theorem for progressions
of length three instead of using a
pigeonhole principle you can use van
Devere dance theorem so the idea is that
once you prove some cases abandoned
serum and you can use those to prove
later cases or as mathematicians will
say the argument is an argument by
inductions what I've shown you is the
first not completely obvious inductive
step of an inductive argument explaining
a mass result sometimes you know some
people explain something in a talk using
a board and the ideas all seem very
clear and if you go back and look at the
paper which is the same argument but
presented a less visual form using
symbols and stuff decoding what it says
is can be quite a difficult process